cani carini the game non è proprio
questo però mi fa piacere che ci sia un
canino carino con le cuffie c'è
l'italiano l'inglese l'italiano pazzesco
non esiste determinare determino
determina mi tutto pazzesco un primo
gioco italiano che vedo horror nuova
partita impostazioni sviluppatore
esentato non è proprio italiano però ci
ha già difficoltà c'è la difficoltà
questa che penso sia sempre 60 date poi
c'è questa che difficoltà punto poi
difficoltà pazzesca potresti essere un
accanito fan dello spazio morto nicchia
come sono iscritto al suo canale
comunque sia prescindere da questo sono
molto curioso di vedere che cosa succede
anche perché non ho i dati che gioco sia
però determino determina determina
porca vacca ragazze gioco puzzle
e partito benissimo
mischia sembra l'aquila camera di
sicurezza brandico a uno studente quei
giochi che c'erano sulle sale giochi
bellissimo
e tutto normale a casa mia niente di
strano
ho visto 62 cadaveri nel mentre che
facevo questa qua io sto facendo niente
della sbagliano due bellissimo
chissà dove andiamo a finire
ma la ferratura ci
limita d'arcais
oddio
quest'anno flickr hanno le mani tutto a
posto e vabbè
quindi sono vivo
sono che devo fare
io sono serio sono sveglio sono sempre
puntuali sono sveglio
buongiorno certo che sono ancora vivo
tra tecniche penserà che poi 162mila e
horror a ma è un gioco in j in terza
persona cioè mi muovo così bellissimo
belli altro cioè sono vestite come na
scout ma non sono anche per la gnocca se
fosse però è bellissimo perché non siamo
proprio il campeggio posso passare qui
vorrei proprio entra il quadrato
madonna di sole anche leggendo così
felice tra questo vedendo delle robe che
non vorrei vedere vai al passaggio al
primo piano bella st testa c'è un
ragnetto è la cosa più carina che ho
visto devo dire che ci prova avrà niente
bene benissimo che arrivano di corsa da
quando so che mi ha seguito e satana io
sto tornando di tranquillamente esiste
solo adesso c'è chi ha definito l'inter
e non posso leggerti sono l'ansia sola
quando cio lanzani non leggo schivata
con chiave di esecuzione va bene
posso schivare con chiave l'esecuzione
di ritorni suo gioco ha avuto tirare una
schivata
ma io ma perché sta giocando sta roba
praticamente sono io quando la gente mi
chiede di fare la mia heathrow il
pubblico divertente stavano ragazzi dove
è morto morto posso avvicinarmi a
prendere la tua pistola da avere in mano
sto male pistola ad alta potenza va bene
edwards o tre colpi che bello che ci ha
colpiti vicino visti così bellissimo e
posso andare di qua peccato perché un
abisso alta potenza non autorizzata
posso spaccare questo con la pistola
alta potenza propria e la madonna quanta
potenza e questa pistola data potenza si
è aperto a unasca mica troppo miss
spaccava la facciata scavava bene belga
che succede che è successo
oddio cesta un ghostbuster sui sul
soffitto
chi è
ma chi è questo psico mantis sull italia
scala veloce veloce
la donna che portava nato buongiorno
mi scusi devo schivare madonna
è l'amore va bene
porca [ __ ] e doveva doveva dove fa cosa
faccio
salì veloce per favore
in tremila mariah perché era una casa
testata alla scala per farmi così male
mi sembra un po eccessivo
dove devo andare cosa devo fare aiuto ti
prego sali la scala
forse ce l'ho fatta stavolta è forse ce
l'ho fatta luca
minchia senso anche quello vabbè allora
bravi ragazzi ma un attimo di tre questo
gioco ce l'abbiamo e tutto così ma
neanche in aria di isole show ciao come
stai per l'amore di dio ragazzina attimo
c'è
quello che stai dicendo mi interessa se
libri a
cerca di distruggere i loro alti ma
questo è scemo dove dove come donna
sono incastrato nel
ai fischietti schiaffo ma dato va bene
tutto a posto è poi solo preso degli
schiaffi in the face ma
ha posto c'è uno zio con la motosega che
in confronto outlast è il gioco
ufficiale dei teletubbies kit di pronto
soccorso di servirebbe anche adesso che
mi sono beccato due schiaffi che me li
ricordo
saleh
c'era un tizio può anche porca [ __ ]
le tue sorella morta un secchio
posseduto questa
e se solo per aver impedito di
rovesciare
è frate venir i fatti i cazzi tuoi
perché sta pistola tanta potenza
non aspetta nessuno questo sto dicendo
però non vedo nessuno
e lei
mi chiamo giovanni
come ti chiami tu branco dove che ha
dato lo zio
guanti mentali barba bene io posso posso
vabbè che potrebbe servire st marciano
infinito è una skin tipo league of
legends porca [ __ ]
guanti mentali guanti mentali e non
funzionano più perché sono in contanti
l'anci
el'upi e quanta gente collegamento
vertibili della seconda si vabbè ma non
muoiono
di alta finché the mountain
che ne so
arca vacca lo spaccato bravo continua a
camminare li bravissimo dell'idea
aspetta un attimo che dover caricare ok
posto e 3 e 2 e 1
benissimo che c'è la fascetta che mi
dice se stai bene o no bellissima sta
roba
cos'è che mi dice che devo buttare
qualcosa ma non posso da quanti metalli
thank you
i quarti in italy per [ __ ] le robe
agli altri bellissimo un guaio burst
urologici guanti mentali e niente ma
dov'è che devo andare
capitan a
e vabbè io sto sparando che devo farli
così
la donna di dio
tutto a posto ragazzi questo è
crocifisso praticamente che è successo
guardalo siete veramente la posizione su
questa ma com'è possibile per terra
tanto se lo staff attendono altro tizio
va bene me ne vado sotto piacere ragazzi
comunque veramente non sono in grado di
qua
perché a me l'aspettavo va bene o merda
la pistola che la pista una pistola la
pistola vista la mano
porca [ __ ]
quanta gente madonna che fastidio
carica
ice mi servirebbero colpi
per la madre che vuole stupido questo
dai guanti mentali
lo slow creato praticamente era bloccato
lo slow calo un genio e corri corri
corri corri corri corri corri minchia
preso colpi
donna
non è morto
grandi che culo
vabbè
ho un kit medico ringraziare dio perché
sto morendo veramente sono messo
malissimo
ok perfetto very nice
ma che cazzo succede quei ragazzi tutto
bene
non ho propriamente capito cosa stia
succedendo però va bene
cosa che si apre questo rumore
a 6 staccata la corrente posso passare
nice non ho più colpita è
sto dicendo no più colpi
mi sa che ma perfetto sono morto
che
cos'è che è successo si è piantata in
faccia una roba ma se avesse sbattuto il
caso c'e veramente un nemesis cori
scappa c'è il nemesis vabbè vabbè la
madonna gli occorrerà in attimo dove
vado muoio sono morto non ci passa per
la porta si ci passa sono morto a meno
che non faccia così
non viene fregato niente non gliene è
fregato niente è andato in allora se io
faccio questa cosa adesso ok
merda
tempio perché
le sue selezioni più ascolto dopotutto
lo [ __ ] lo [ __ ]
merda
non solo di andare aiuto dove vado vado
di quando aiuto e devo fare il giro
teoricamente faccio giro madonna rialzo
va bene gioco incredibile questo ragazzo
è un'ansia terribile e terrificante
aspetta
rifacciamo il giro di nuovo così tanto
vorrei far saltare sprofondo sai però ho
paura che non gli faccia niente quindi
me ne vado di quale ne vado di quante ne
vado io me ne vado di come le vale qua
non ci credo chiude si chiude a posto
mica tattica nuke incoming direttamente
la modern warfare 2
oh merda
no no sì sì va bene arrivederci e stato
bello
madonna ragazzi che di gioco ansiolitico
al massimo e non ho mai fatto una cosa
del genere ma quanta ansia in gioco solo
fatemi reattivo riprendere perché
veramente non ho mai giocato alla roba
così ragazzi che poi ci sono anche le
armi vabbè che è successo
nicchia dei topi la cosa più bella che
ho visto la voglia iniziato suo gioco
schiacciando lo so ho aperto qualcosa
vabbè ci passerò crociato ma ci passo
tra era che c'è quel tizio lì che
veramente frutto è attaccato al muro lo
zio tipo quelli residenti volo vediamo
atmosfera impossibile il ragazzo
abrate
giusta lo zio
tutta la tua sorella che fa le sedie
perforare per foriamo
per favore se chiusa questa ottimo
kick ass salve
compito attuale by all'uscita ma chissà
qual era il mio compito prima invece è
che facciamo qui a col tasto 0
ma [ __ ]
chi sei
e morto quanti tutto usato porca [ __ ] e
vabbè mica lo spaccato di brutto bene è
andata benissimo punizione per fucili
quale fucili san leone anche uno quale
fucili non c'è né sul fucile qua dice
fucile parliamo
madonna di dio
trovato bello ok
perforare per foriamo
non o fucili ma fa niente ragazzi state
ferme per cortesia fermi e perché già
già è difficile per
una colonna vertebrale ma grazie ma ma
non dove prima grazie che è bello che mi
pensate ogni tanto sapete che mi
piacciono questi regali improvvisi
inaspettati tra l'altro c'è qualcuno
quando il muro lo vedo chi sei dove
porta l'oscurità avrò un futuro siamo la
comunità di destini condivisi che tra
sono mondi paralleli si intreccia
insieme c'è un futuro prima di te non ho
fatto in tempo a leggere però
il gioco è finito c'è un inquadratura su
un corridoio
e mi torna il menu
no non posso aver giocato a sta roba
perfino dai ragazzi io non ho idea
veramente questo che io abbia appena
giocato ragazzi spero che non ci sia
piaciuto un video tranquillo rispetto al
solito meno male di schede a karaj
lasciato bel commento qua sotto seguito
è piaciuto e cosa che noi ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo vi do beh ragazzi
[Musica]